[Musique]
donald trump continue de crier victoire
et de déposer des recours contre de
supposées fraudes électorales et
pourtant les autorités locales et
nationales ont affirmé que l'élection du
13 du 3 novembre a été la plus sûre de
l'histoire des etats-unis joe biden lui
continue de creuser l'écart en nombre de
grands électeurs après sa victoire
confirmée en arizona
je pense que le temps dira qu'à
l'administration nous aurons quoi il
suffit pas tu à l'avenir qui sait je
peux vous dire que cette mutation ne
posera pas de loughner de la musique et
des dizaines de personnes agglutinées
qui font la fête à l'intérieur de cette
maison
la scène publiées sur les réseaux
sociaux s'est déroulé hier soir dans ce
pavillon de joinville le pont en
banlieue parisienne une fête clandestine
qui a réveillé tout le voisinage
[Musique]
une soirée qui rassemblait non pas 50
mais plus de 300 convives et qui s'est
terminé en bagarre générale avant d'être
dispersés par les policiers à l'aide de
grenades de désencerclement comme on le
voit sur cette autre vie des croyants
nakamura
j'adore j'adore ce qu'elle fait d'avoir
raté raté raté reprendre de volée un
mois nous a plantés il ya nakamura nous
implanter pas il ya 24 heures non il ya
une heure une demi heure elle nous a pas
appelés l'on peut apprendre à me dire en
même temps on avait dans une story mais
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est ce que
l'euphorie de la sortie du dollar mais
tous les jeunes frères
c'est vrai que j'ai été un peu
j'ai pas été vigilante c'est vrai que
sur ce coup là mais j'étais tellement
content d'eux
de préférer la sortie de mon album
homonyme
ouais mais la prochaine fois je ferai
plus attention et je mettrai
et mettra des masques nous sommes des
êtres humains c'est à dire qu'on aime
lire on aime rire on aime boire un petit
coup de temps à ôter la bonne cuisine
c'est la france les français aiment le
couscous m la pizza essayé d'interdire
le couscous et la pizza vous allez voir
ce que ça va donner passer des livres à
la pizza merci beaucoup julien mais oui
et le livre c'est comme une une sorte de
pizza intellectuelle les pâtes à la
bolognaise me souviens des mythologies
de barthes et parmi les mythologies en
1957 il y avait le steak frites qui
était la france dans ce qu'elles avaient
de continuer de ridicule et maintenant
ce qu'aiment les français c'est le
couscous coulanges leurs plats préférés
et la pizza sans commentaire puisqu'on
représente aujourd'hui c'est quand même
le premier employeur de france
d'accord moi j'ai dit on et les globules
rouges de la france sinon tous la france
qui sera malade on peut l'oublier ça il
faut faire attention parce que tout le
monde est à cran aujourd'hui il faut
dire que les remonter on les as de la
base des mecs temps peuvent plus le
discours qui tenait au mois de mars au
mois d'avril
aujourd'hui c'est plus le même alors
faut faire attention
c'est une réalité un restaurant sur deux
pourrait fermer définitivement d'ici
quelques mois
je lis comme son nom l 13 ans tout de
suite ça provoque et de la zénitude ça
apaise moi aujourd'hui j'ai trois
enfants
j'ai deux enfants à charge je sais à
corps en jeu mêlant donne à manger
demain je ne sais pas comment je paye ma
mutuelle
la dernière fois que j'allais faire des
courses jamais une vertes' je ne sais
pas de quoi demain est fait donc si vous
voulez il faut intégrer une chose moi le
coc vide ce dont je suis sûr c'est que
je ne mourrai pas dû qu'au vide
par contre je viens mourir de tous les
effets collatéraux du coc bide
est-ce que vous avez aidé d
encouragement pour tous ceux qui nous
écoutent
comment vont ils s attaquent à jouer je
conseille la lumière le seigneur soit
avec vous et que dieu tout puissant nous
bénisse et nous garde lui qui est père
fils et saint-esprit
dès que la situation sanitaire va le
permettre on va réouvrir pour le 1er
décembre
vous croisez les doigts mais oui parce
que ce ce chalet dire c'est un de com
mais je veux pas dire ça c'est un gros
mot ce terrible sort ce que v2 permet au
moment des faits je vous avais dit que
je songeais à faire un geste à toi joue
à me faire tatouer autre chose dessus
alors je pense est un gène mans où par
exemple j'aimerais utiliser des mots
comme bb ou col de l'utérus
enfin vous voyez l'idée quoi notre
crédit culte quoi tu parles col de
l'utérus c'est quoi ça c'est un des cols
du tour de france il doit être bien
chaud à grimper avec un nom pareil on
peut trouver des livres par le clic est
emporté j'ai veillé à ce que ça vous dit
pas click and collect a vraiment vous
avez suivi ségolène royal qui sociale
leur prochaine il faut arrêter de dire
non au ballon c'est ségolène royal qui
me suivent avons très bien voilà je
plaisante
j'ai pas dire que c'est une private joke
ou leurs alliés
non mais ça sera à bulles les centres de
lavage n'étant pas considérée comme
commerce essentiels pendant confinement
c'est pas la peine d'y amener votre
voiture pour le nettoyage de banquette
arrière vous repasserez en revanche pour
le nettoyage de la biquette arrière mais
je suis visiblement c'est possible
bon ça à la vache
j'espère qu'on doit croiser personne en
sens inverse et le gps était en islande
et c'est pas possible
l'impression qu'on engueule à chaque
fois qu'elle en est un homme qui a les
épaules pour être avec vous en ce moment
peut-être
j'ai cru comprendre que vous avez un peu
officialisé une relation non ah bon au
programme
ah ouais d'accord je sais pas peut-être
et c'est vrai que ce jour là j'ai
rencontré raphaël par hasard maîtresses
vous avez rencontre le 14 14 samedi le 5
ans jour pour jour il ya cinq ans jour
pour jour exactement marc et moi le 13
le 13 novembre le jour des attentes nées
en 2007 en 2007 13 novembre quand même
tous les 13 novembre sont plus rien fait
c'était un sketch que j'avais fait chez
michel drucker juste après l'allier le
début l'histoire d'amour entre carla
bruni nicolas sarkozy et donc j'avais
une phrase sur un une petite saucisse et
plein de fayots tout rendre au nom de
toutes les personnes qui me préparer
cette célébration
merci pour votre présence merci pour
votre soutien
prenez bien soin de vous et de vos
proches
très prudent